[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to day six
of the 2022 fall chess Classic this is
the sixth round we've officially crossed
that halfway point and this is kind of
that portion in the tournament where
maybe you start to see who's pulling
ahead who might be able to become a
winner this is going to be where all the
action really starts and my name is
Jonathan schrance I'm very happy to be
joined here with Miro and Miro are you
looking forward to seeing anything
special today uh well first of all hi
everybody and yeah round six is where at
least
I think fair to say more than half of
the people was called score more than
I'm in my last year it was pathetic yeah
so what I'm saying
uh still nothing is clear in the B
tournament but I believe today today
something important is going to happen
in the 80s like we will get verifying
rounds yeah I think we will get the
clear leader look like so let's go ahead
and get an idea of what is happening
starting with these standings for the a
group in the a group we do have two
people with three and a half points that
is very Gujarati and Gregory o'parin now
and Three Points we have Yu Yang Yi and
Von Nguyen at two and a half we have
Hans Neiman and ilyones we also have
armacobian sitting at two and a half
below that ejat absov is sitting on two
points three again ghouli has a point
and a half and Nicholas theodoro has a
full point now Miro can you let us know
what's going on in the B group yeah B
group as we've already figured out well
they tend to play many more games with
uh you know decisive games right and
therefore
uh half a point more than the a group is
a tie for the first so we still have
round like sadwani after the brilliant
star tree out of three Well he kind of
slowed down a little bit with two draws
in a row and he is caught by Christopher
U Alexander monster this is the leading
group four out of five here died for the
first clear four spot three uh 305
gergely Contour then we have Dennis
cartridge Brandon Jacobson uh Brent
Jacobson already on two right so these
three top guys they basically scored all
the plus right leaving more than half a
tournament in minor score around
mccallion still after this one draw the
round before he lost one more game sits
only on half a point out of five that is
right and as you can see here this was
some footage taken as the round was just
starting you can see all of the players
for the first time they are playing in
the Chase Park Plaza and here you can
kind of see uh this room that was set up
just specifically for this turn
tournaments on the site might also be
the home for some of our future events
as well but for now let's go ahead and
get to know the format of today's
tournaments there are two 10 player
round Robins we got the a group and the
B group it is 90 minutes for the first
40 moves then they get 30 minutes at
move 40 which they get for the rest of
the game there's also a 30 second
increments and every single move Miro
could you please let us know about the
schedule for the events yep the
remaining schedule means today tomorrow
day after tomorrow all the regular
rounds start at 1pm and the last one on
November 10th will start two hours
earlier because in case of a playoff and
it's not very unlikely to have a
playoffs where you see a lot of people
tied at the moment in both tournaments
we have a tie for the first dwell in the
current uh as it currently stands so the
playoff if necessary will be played on
the same 10th November at 5 PM that is
right and just like always we are
watching you guys we are watching the
chat you're on Twitch you're on YouTube
maybe you're on you uschestchance.com
wherever you are and watching us welcome
to the show and if you do want to join
in with us on social media please use
the hashtag fall chess classic you can
watch us on us justjams.com and of
course any bits donations or any money
that we received through YouTube through
twitch it all is going to a really
amazing cause it is going to get
Scholastic programming for children in
the St Louis area so kids that might
otherwise not have access to a full
semester of Chess programming we'll be
getting it and it's all thanks to you
guys so thank you so much for everything
that you have contributed uh so far and
with that in mind let's go ahead and see
who is playing today in the a group now
we have in the a group Ilya niesnick
going up against Von Nguyen Surya
Ganguly versus Yu Yang Yi Nicholas
theodoro versus Armin Jacobian vire
Gujarati versus nijan absov and our game
of the day a very important one for the
standings
Gregory o'parin versus Hans Neiman
Gregory one of the leaders of the event
Hans one point behind him
uh oh yeah and they've started quite
similarly the tournament right it's a
three yeah it was first but then Gregory
kind of figured out yeah well actually
you have to start winning if you found
the magic sauce and he's got himself all
the way up to first place all right Hans
yet to score anything else than a drone
all right but what is going on how did
what's going on in the game let's get to
know what is happening all right yes
let's see well if anything
uh I do like hans's position
we got the Rooks on the open file you
seem to really like these open files is
that the reason or is there something
else well it just feels that yeah like
pretty much anything that could
potentially gone wrong for white
actually did
so the knights are well the night on the
street is not bad but I'd prefer the
other one on F5 brother rather than F1
right and the king is not perfectly safe
black is much more active indeed on the
D file and don't be fooled with this
doubled pawns right so the C4 Pawn plays
a major roles a white uh sorry black
gets a very nice outpost on D3 so
whenever yeah like white technically
challenges black on the D file but
whenever he attempts to take on D3 and
then if the Rook captures yes of course
white be happy to trade the other Rook
but black will capture with the Poland
that'll be very annoying passport on D3
how did all this happen I mean so a lot
has happened here black has somehow
managed to get a very comfortable
position yeah let's see what the opening
was it was uh it was actually for a
change yeah maybe that's the the main
mistake on move three not the Joker
piano line yeah so whoever seen a lot of
Italian games in this uh tournament but
every now and then you got to see every
Lopez so and them to play the Berlin on
Thai Berlin with d2d3 Bishop to C5 and
Knight B to D2 and I think we've seen
yeah this looks very similar to
something that we've seen in our other
Ray Lopez game from this game
so Knight B to D2 is
um well I think even even someone who
played this line I don't remember I
believe it was the B tournament someone
from the big tour he played the song he
said yes of course Knight bd2 kind of it
doesn't bring white the advantage if
Lexus knows everything this is nice when
you see the Ray Lopez it's so nice to
see something that's not a Berlin end
game though you know absolutely just
give us anything else sir Castle's
Knight to B3 okay so that's the idea
attack the bishop Bishop goes to D6 yeah
it's a little bit awkward for this
bishop uh because yeah like if you
perhaps you you'd like to put it on B6
but then the benefit of White's previous
move is the default square is covered
and then Bishop takes Pawn takes white
can actually take on E5 because with the
Knight elsewhere so quite often it would
be with the Knight on C3 right and then
black has Queen D4 targeting F2 and the
Knight on E5 so that's that's usually
the trick that saves interesting idea
from White it saves black at the pawn
but in this case black has to go to D6
anyway castles Rook E8 Bishop G5 okay
Bishop H6 even though it was the rui
Lopez we still get this Joko piano Vibes
with Bishop to G5 A6
Bishop traded and we have everything
pretty much everything in once and now
it also looks a bit like what's that
called through developers exchange
variation right
right it ended up trading on C6 Knight
f2d2 okay so he keeps the Knight on B3
uh all right Bishop here F3 Bishop E6
and somewhere around this point already
you can you can kind of feel that the
white is not getting
uh what he wanted to get
because yes you've doubled the pawns yes
you potentially have access to this at
five square but white is nowhere near in
time for all that so Bishop F2 Queen E7
Knight F1 said the Knight starts its
journey to F5 and C4 that's a bold move
yeah like C4 D takes B takes Knight D2
Bishop B4
it's a very annoying pin well perhaps
not that one but if white doesn't react
there will be a pin on the D file right
okay so he goes C3 Bishop to C5 then and
that is perhaps somewhat
counter-intuitive but tend to be a very
strong move Bishop F2 and King takes F2
that's
unexpected I want to say Knight to H5 G3
a check is a very clever move it seems
so then Knight E3 I presume some Knight
F4 would be possible and then yeah and
the Knight is pinned and therefore very
dangerous hey yep so therefore King goes
to G2 then black just plays logical
moves Rook a to B8 attack the pawn Rook
d8 take the open file Rook to D3 Rook to
d8 Rook B to D1 Queen C6 so Queen C6
targeting this guy and also this you
know the opposition of black screen and
white skin hints at some I don't know G4
sometimes yeah F5 who knows so that's
once again very pleasant for black and
it just kind of I don't know was it just
some small inaccuracy or something
somehow just this Advantage for black it
just seemed to kind of effortlessly yeah
grow here looks very nice not even clear
where where exactly white went wrong
right I mean it seems like a set of
really minor inaccuracies
smaller yeah smaller movement here
smaller move there and and all of a
sudden it kind of adds up to Black being
clearly better wow all right so we're
definitely going to be keeping our eyes
on this one for now Hans and even with a
slight advantage against his opponent
looks very dangerous so we will
obviously be keeping an eye uh with what
is going on here now in our B group we
also have some very exciting and
important uh pairings Mira when you go
ahead and let us know what we got today
so as we have three leaders it's
literally impossible that they all play
each other right but we've got two of
the three anyway we start with tigran
harutinyan facing gergelicante then
Brenda Jacobson against against akshat
Chandra realnak sadwani one of the
leaders has the white pieces against
Dennis cutridge that's a very
interesting game I've checked the
position already then Christian carrilla
against Armand michelian Christian with
white will be looking to try to you know
score something but yeah that's that's
the game of the day to leaders both
represent the United States facing each
other Christopher Rio Alex lenderbond
four out of five uh Chris Christopher
having the white pieces all right so
this one is absolutely huge both of
these players with four uh out of Five
Points so far uh let's go ahead and see
what is going on with their game today
all right a lot is that fast
comparatively to the last game yeah
that's one tricky position on the board
I'm not even sure uh how to how do you
what do you how do you evaluate
something like this because optically at
first I mean the first thing you notice
is white spawns here and that of course
makes it very optimistic about White's
chances but then the pawns are currently
blocked right
also somewhat somewhat uh attacked the
pawn on E5 let's say so I reckon White
can try to take on A7 but then something
something along the lines of Bishop G4
maybe so an attempt to trade the Knight
on F3 capture the E5 Pawn maybe it's not
as bad for by for black as it might seem
originally we could quickly run through
this game how do we get here because
this is very complicated they made a lot
of moves already oh yeah so that's the
pet roof and how do you get such
positions against the petrol well let me
ask yeah so now it takes D takes E5 not
the most common okay d75 Knight to D2
and that's a funny move Queen D7 which
might surprise you but in fact yeah
that's something that people do Play
Bishop D3 Knight to C5 castles
captured here there should be seven
rookie one castles D4 and queen to G4 so
that's the whole kind of the whole setup
was the screen the queen goes there then
if needed Bishop goes to F5 or even G4
so black has a very firm control over
the line squares so King Knight F1 Queen
to G6 okay G6 is a also a square that
makes sense Bishop to G4
all right and now
uh so one of the questions would be what
happens if Queen D5 is played but
perhaps some Rook d8 or even Knight C6 I
don't see any immediate tactics but
uh just something
anyway white starts with H3 so white
basically goes for some tricks H3 Bishop
H3 Knight G3 it's a white sacrifice the
pawn but now the bishop is hanging D5 is
hanging and B7 is interesting so black
is forced to move the bishop back all
the way apish to C8 Queen Capstone D5
Knight C6 Queen C4 then once again yeah
so we can see how I got these extra
Center pawns here yeah so once again I
mean if black is fully developed like
say gets the time to play Bishop G4 Rook
knd8 he's probably better never mind the
center because of two Bishops you know
somewhat weakened a white King's
position uh but it's all about the
timing right because D5 is a strong
threat so Knight to B4 and white doesn't
really react to Knight C2 thread because
apart from Knight C2 the other kind of
more positional but in a way even more
convincing thread that black has is to
play Bishop E6 and then put the Knight
or maybe even the bishop to D5 live and
stop the advance of those pawns so
Christopher you goes with a chain
sacrifice into D5 Knight to C2 yes
challenge has to be accepted Bishop B3
that's that is yeah okay now c7's
hanging white girl C6 D6 Bishop two d8
and A4 so it's a clear exchange so I
suspect if we ask a computer it's like
Black's position but sure in Practical
yeah it's very multi-realistic yeah but
in a practical game who knows what's all
that the queen to G4 white even
interesting it doesn't mind to trade the
queens and just just you know set those
spawns in motion F6 F4 okay traded
Bishop H4 Knight E4 now the Knight is
headed to C5
Rook 88 Knight F3 Bishop goes back uh by
the way it seems that
yeah black could have captured here and
on E5
okay I'm not sure what once again what
what kind of the position what kind of
position is that maybe maybe the Deep
one is still kind of threatening but it
would be the way to bail out with black
already that means
so that means since he went Bishop d8 I
believe he's not scared of this point
right he could have captured so Bishop
d8 Bishop A7 uh seven is not yet played
okay so they're sitting here in his
white to play
oh yeah we'll be fascinating so I mean
Mike must be really happy and
comfortable kind of yeah with the
position
um but you know if those pawns are
blockaded they're not going anywhere
yeah right but but only for now and who
knows yeah yeah like some Knight C5 is
is an option as well Knight C5 Bishop G4
yeah it's probably anything white does
black player plans to play Bishop G4
okay anyway that's that's you can can't
ask for much more yeah the game between
two leaders some people would interject
you know they didn't just change yeah
or something yeah there's an action in
it awesome so we're definitely gonna
keep our eye here see what transpires in
this game uh but for now why don't we
just kind of go around the horn maybe we
can get a kind of a feel uh for what is
going on with all of the rest of the
games is there anywhere you'd like to go
Mira uh yeah well let's just go one by
one a tournament tournament and that's
uh foreign
having the white pieces and
not such a pleasant position I'm afraid
all right not such a pleasant position
I'm afraid those doubled pawns uh well
they are kind of weak slightly and also
limit The Bishop's activity right so
Bishop B2 you'd like to play perhaps but
but not in this position right not with
the pawn on C3 but Ilya is known for
kind of escaping absolutely that's
definitely the style plays kind of
non-theoretical which sometimes means
you get a bad position but it's very
hard to beat him although we did see
after we left Yu Yang Yi was able to uh
defeat Ilya yesterday managed to convert
against Ilia
all right so actually rookie three would
be one and rookie one
so now
is there any chance we see a draw here
uh not really are they playing these
moves oh wait a second you going back he
did repeat he did repeat yes I'll count
this one right at the end it was a check
and Rook D3 rookie three right so there
is the potential that this one just ends
here uh I was thinking black could
actually play Knight H5 point being yeah
attacking F4 and
okay it's not really a trap but sort of
right so E4 Pawn cannot be taken
um but you know I guess we can go all
the way to the top of this game and just
go through it whether people are saying
it or not see let's see Hello in stream
yeah exactly all right yeah let us give
us like a give us a thumbs up or a heart
or something if you can hear us I just
want to make sure we're talking to
somebody but we can talk to ourselves
just as well
so how did we get here in this game by
playing the names of Defense
castles E3 C5 A3
and the Google it's like a sandwich but
it started with E3 uh and then only A3 a
little bit later yeah all right D6 and
E5 and that's kind of a good
old-fashioned setup uh wait wait a
second but good old-fashioned but good
old-fashioned does not involve
sacrificing the pawn so that that's
something new to me at least ah let me
let me check Bishop D3
was played not on High level but well
some I feel like this is not quite the
same move order if you start with A3
immediately because sometimes they're
playing with like F3 so if the sandwich
damage would mean the opponents on F3
right anyway this is a little different
it turns out that as early as move eight
in the names of Indian he's a novelty
okay at least according to the database
we have all right and it looks like it's
white that has been prepared so this
probably wasn't something that was
prepped by black it looks like black had
actually spent 22 minutes or so to get
to this point it could be so maybe just
coming up with something on the spot and
decides to sack a pawn yeah white
captures Queen to E7 and perhaps you
know with this double pawns and black
having the free development
there are always going to be some
compensation at the very least if white
just calmly goes away Bishop Bishop E6
Knight C6 Knight A5 if needed will
Target the pawn right Rooks in the
centers
yeah definitely hoping to get enough
activity here yeah and white plays F4 F4
Knight to D7 and then Knight back to F3
uh while not sure how I feel about this
Knight D7 move because the Knight is
misplaced it would be much better on C6
anyway so B7 B6 Bishop to B7 uh White is
a pawn up but it's very hard to push the
pawn forward and with the pawn on E3
this guy is quite stupid the pawns are
still weak yeah probably black is like
at least not worse than
uh okay Rook a to d8 once again if I may
suggest at probably I'd probably look at
Knight E4 immediately because yeah just
you know knowing what happened to Rook
88 white did play E4 so this way black
gets the pawn back but at least white
gets some sort of like frees up his
position a little bit Queen to D5 Queen
F7 yeah so here it turns out you can't
really take E4 because one of the Rooks
to E8 right right X-ray on this Rook
so A4 Knight F6 traded A5 and this is
pretty much how we've gotten there H6
king of one
Knight G4 and back rookie three a couple
of checks and here we are yeah okay so
we're waiting uh
I don't know does it feel like black
should be trying to play for something a
little bit more here uh yeah yeah still
I believe it's it's black who is trying
so perhaps objectively it's already
closer to a draw or
maybe just equal but the black is out of
risk for sure all right well black is
going to take a little bit of time here
and think and see if they can find a way
to come up with an advantage here while
that's going on yeah we can go ahead and
take a look at yet another game uh yeah
why don't we check video to visit
against the boss of you that's a very
very original
uh position or rather position might be
might be looking fine but if I'd ask
here
um
how did the king ended up on B1 so well
logically it'd be a long Castle but the
answer is no what the answer is how did
he get there I was checking this game
like like before we went live and well
it starts with ever Evergreen very
popular sure London we're gonna have one
sister E3
and it's going to be six move okay ah
and that's why you well
it's no that yeah if you want to play
London you probably play with Bishop F4
right so you usually do not rush with
Knight F3 and here the move for big
Knight D2 so that Queen B6 is kind of
less annoying it's like 26 and uh White
announce this yeah B2 is hanging which
is quite unpleasant but yeah why just
girls not details says if you want to
take take it's very risky C takes e
takes uh Nija decided yeah it's too much
taking on B2 I'm not even sure what the
theory is perhaps something like
something aggressive with an immediate
C4
anyway so Bishop to G4 Knight B3 so this
time
that it says but now of course you know
uh you had the chance to take this Pawn
but not anymore Knight to D7 captures on
G6 so it's like many opening lines in
one line because uh H3 G4 and then
trading the bishop on G6 usually wire H4
not E5 uh would look like some lines in
the French uh sorry not French but it's
love defense yeah yeah the slav defense
but then for whatever reason you have
the Knight on B3 and it's a very
original setup Bishop G2 Bishop D6 yeah
would keep those Bishops on the board
Queen E2 Knight B6 C3 Knight to C4 and
white girls Knight D2 quote unquote
blundering the pawn not really because
Queen B5
so Knight takes and pawn takes
all right yeah and takeaway is the pawn
perhaps makes a lot of sense otherwise
black would have gotten the square on F4
for the bishop but this allows black to
give a check and force the king to D1
and so this is how the king slowly gets
over there we can start to tell how he
got over castles King to C2 E5 G5
any five perhaps is not not IDL The Rook
F1
he takes he takes rookie 8 Rook to D1
King to B1 and this is how we've gotten
there Knight back to B3 and all of a
sudden yeah they've started to play like
slow positional moves Knight C1 while
covers E2 for now and also kind of heads
towards towards D3 which is perhaps the
best yeah arguably the best Square here
A5
black had to stop night before because
it's really awkward to protect the D5
Pawn
so as far as I can tell why it perhaps
has some Advantage here simply because
the Knight on H5 is currently out of the
game yeah it does feel like black might
have a little bit of coordination issues
with some of the pieces here and this is
a huge one because vidit is also one of
the leaders in the a group so it will be
interesting to keep our eyes on this one
because the video can win yet another
game I mean he's really starting to run
away with this one so we'll keep our
eyes as well a lot to talk about today
are there any other games yeah
absolutely so we still remember of
course of operating enhance but yeah
let's quickly check the other two sure
Ganguly against you young Yi and if
it has one Queen and black has zero
Queens oh wait that's a lot of those
Queens I'm about to say wait how many
pieces yeah I'm about to say white is a
queen now but let's let's count the
pieces on the other side because it's
got a couple of nights in the room oh
yes and that means wait a minute it's
like there's more right black has more
this could be really good for boys how
do we get here this is this is insane uh
it's only move 26 and that's unusual to
I almost want to say black is winning I
mean with such material because we're
getting getting deeper into the
tournament I don't know if it's people
trying harder to win or if it's fatigue
or whatever it is but it seems like
today we are being treated so it's just
a lot of very exciting games okay yeah
so that's an interesting thing here
Knight to F6 which is rarely played I
believe but then I see once again a name
of one Magnus Carlsen who recently
played it was relatively sounds like a
good move to me uh played it with black
so check
black has to block with the Knight okay
I reckon yeah except basically if you if
you block with the bishop that one white
can trade and go C4 and boy does get
some compensation but that's an extra
Pawn like kind of for real after Knight
D7 if you if you try to protect the pawn
C4 uh black would go with A6 and then B5
and getting
sort of a banker type compensation white
girls with Knight F3 but black still
goes for A6 and then B5 and Bishop B7
castles Bishop D5 so that's actually a
very very comfortable position for black
D4 E6 A4 B4 White's tail tries to be
ambitious with A4 B4 A5
nailing down this
A6 still so far I have no idea how we
got to that juicy position from here
yeah how does what's happening how does
win one win the Queen Bishop G5 Bishop
B7 Knight D2 okay B takes B takes
castles Knight to E5 C D4 CD4 so far
uh still not that easy to tell and queen
to c3e
and hang on and white went Knight C4
looks like white kind of hallucinated a
little
yeah he simply blonded Knight C4 Bishop
C4 rookie three so he thought maybe when
this bishop I'm trapping the queen or if
the queen goes to B4 I suspect something
like that was the plan yeah Knight C6 is
not really because Queen D6 so that was
a really really strange Nazi form of and
he overlooked what here we looked was
Queen takes Queen takes Knight takes and
then the default is Spain Ah that's so
nice Okay so this looks like it was just
a blunder then he yeah Rook to B1 Knight
G6 just to keep everything safe and
sound Knight to D5
Bishop to G5 and Bishop B5 yeah there
you go so it looks like even though
black is without the queen flag is very
comfortable yeah
he's just winning
or rather he has won as I was this game
is actually officially over and uh we
have a very special treat because we are
going to be doing interviews a little
bit differently today we are actually
going to be having the players right
here in the seats so in just a moment we
will have you Yang Yi sitting right here
next to Miro for an interview
oh yep
all right so uh well we get them on
there maybe you can look at a game and
we'll have you in just a moment yeah we
will wait for you to run in the studio
so meanwhile just quickly I'll click
through the last game remaining which is
the last game that we didn't pay
attention to it was theodoro against
Jacobian uh here
that's what let's move 36.
and for quite some time they're playing
this strange looking to my eye strange
looking position where
they have the bishop of opposite colors
white is up a pawn but that's a double
ponzer perhaps shouldn't be anything too
serious but yeah white keeps trying now
Target C7 Pawn you don't really like to
play C6 because check
so it's a little awkward for black steel
I've got a feeling that it was easier
beforehand and now maybe maybe you know
maybe white gets somewhere but of course
you need to calculate such things
anyway we yeah we'll go back to a studio
anytime yep here we are welcome welcome
to the studio Grandmaster you young eve
won today's game
and could you could you please tell us a
little bit because we
we did look and we honestly didn't
understand much so did he blunder and
what was he planning to do and yeah okay
so just yeah if you could tell something
about this game and okay
this game is a very interesting game
yeah D5
in in this year Augusta I plan D5 in
pancake knife 6 in Turkey League
the same idea yes aha yeah maybe in just
a lot interesting sacrifice part yeah
first yeah so white can go here right or
it can go to c44 but then you just play
E6 and because of say this square and
development and black probably has a
very good position yes
ah so the green protection yeah yeah
yes yes
very Knight F3 right yeah
maybe black is okay yeah so still your
girl knight B6 he's sick somehow right
yeah yes sometimes maybe B6 Bishop ah or
maybe B6 Bishop B7 yeah so early Pawn
sacrifices you see Chad this is how it's
done yes
three A6 yeah here I remember maybe
analyze too better ah yes so Bishop A4
is a little bit surprising yeah Bishop
E2 95 and still D4 yeah D4 E6 Castle yes
maybe you can maybe write a slightly
better yeah actually surprising it looks
very normal for us yeah right because
you would expect since let's say it's an
original why this should be original
position but this this one actually
looked very normal right yes and here he
gets the bishopon C2 you captured with
the bishop this looks yeah perhaps fine
yes the next next stop is probably A4
yeah a long thing yeah because
um first I I think a bishop D6 yeah yeah
and yeah pancake take weight
yes create
yeah pancake oh yeah Bishop cake before
yeah before yeah I think a maximum of
nice three yeah maybe 55 pounds ah so
yeah it looks like you you have
everything like great but since no
Castle yet and so on he will probably
yes attack B5 in a very ugly way Knight
A3 yes Bishop D3 but there might be
problems right yes
maybe no DC takes maybe first
anniversary yeah yeah maybe Knight A3
first like like this right I don't know
yeah before Knight B5 and stuff like
that yeah you can be very unpleasant yes
yes so I played people yeah just before
yes okay A4 B4 and he goes A5 yeah A5
Queen C7 yeah ambitious
here I think maybe bishop D6 I don't
know first the bishop of D6 to play
Bishop DC looks no no more yeah I think
I did pancake yeah yeah Bishop C5
uh so he takes uh
I don't know
all right so you were not sure if it's
if it's good for black right yes so
maybe some difficulties with this thing
later on right like Bishop takes he
takes
yeah probably yeah yesterday I wanted to
win yeah you wanted to win we all
realize that yes yes and it worked
nicely for you yeah Bishop E7 Knight D2
so where is his like kind of big mistake
yeah it takes yeah it's normal 95 95.
H6 still he wants to keep the bishop
yeah I think maybe my opponent Miss
Queen's history very important yeah
maybe because it's real it's going to
see three and then yeah here I think
maybe what only move uh overstar
maybe better or like df3 yeah yes
somehow he needs to protect this spawn
and it's not very easy right yes because
Nike adversely you see it I think plus
black slightly yeah better yeah you see
it Rook C8 yeah this is like awkward
Rook C1 you will take the phone yes yeah
this bishop has no way to go yeah maybe
bishop A4 yeah Bishop
a48 I think black is better you have to
d8 and then this guy goes to G6 if
needed Yep looks like Lucas Black is
better it looks like black is better
here yeah and he just Blended
yes no idea to C4 yeah take
like he blundered this uh Knight takes
E5 idea right we need 395 and we saw the
years and he lost but no Rooks he won
yeah you see what I think 95 very
interesting wow Bishop 87.
Rook C3 and Bishop H4 yeah rui five
that's a wow
Bishop F6 first still probably black is
better because of course the Black
Panther because it really for maybe 95.
hi you have a lot of load of
intermediate moves yes yes I think 95
and in the end Bishop to B5 and then
double and win the pawn yes of course
right yeah yeah
and like this before rookie three and
that's of course beautiful idea we
already discussed on the show but yeah
we need 395 and too many too many pieces
yes right is it your first visit to
Saint Louis tell me
you've played here right ah wait a
second you've played in a magnus's uh
yeah right absolutely
[Music]
right third time third time in here yeah
two-time in play summer class summer
class summer class yeah it's just a nice
third time
all right and how does it go for you so
far so far it's been good yes I think
right so good tournament yes it's a nice
tournament I can confirm it's just that
I cannot play chess and hopefully
hopefully it will go okay it already
goes much better than for me I don't
know if you know but the only time I
played it was terrible so good luck with
the remaining end game of the tournament
remaining three hours and yeah and I
will yeah thank you very much and I will
return to the B tournament for now we
have Jake no not Jacobson what I'm
saying guys uh Christopher you and
Alexander Lindemann and I'm looking what
moves we have played in this game yes
that is the position we left long time
ago
uh the polo 97 was captured Bishop G4
Knight D2 G5
Knight H2 Bishop D4 uh well somehow
somehow white managed to take this A7
pawn and not to lose any of his Pawns
and it might seem that A7 Pawn is not
that relevant yeah white is not getting
the past Pawn or anything but
it is important because the dark squares
but like why it's getting a lot of
access to dark's Quest potentially
beasts both B6 and C5
so that that's the position white to
move and five minutes only left for
Alexander Lenderman
it's move 33 though so not a big time
trouble but there is some
all right and it is very good to be back
in studio with you Miro that was an
excellent interview we a very
complicated and interesting game as is
this one that you're looking at right
now yeah but I'm still under impression
with I mean
that that's what happens when you know
27 plus player explained what the game
was because from the outside it looks
okay they just played moves white
blundered black and then it's so much
layers you know so much left behind the
scenes right absolutely it was really
nice and pleasant interview
all right what else is going on catch me
up yeah well I actually think let's go
back to the a tournament because we
still have a game of the of the day
going we have yeah that that's that's
not the game of the day where's the game
of the day uh Hans Neiman what has been
happening when we left it Hans was doing
pretty well yeah Queen C6 was Queen C6
was the last move we've seen and here
operating went for quite a
transformation of the position he went
with Mighty D5 Bishop D5 Rook D3 okay so
the trade here and you can't actually oh
yeah so he's temporarily
piece down but yeah there is the pin on
the D file which black has difficulties
breaking right now it's a very nice
solution here 93 and Rook to B8 okay
let's see
let's see so white has to capture on D5
yes not sure if its Pawn takes or Knight
takes
so if Pawn takes let's imagine black
captures on B2 with a check
all right uh King goes
somewhere hope you're not asking me this
is about to get a little bit crazy but
that that's the problem like like I want
to say somewhere but I don't see the
square would which would be like clearly
preferable over the others because King
G1
uh black will be happy to play Queen C5
and pin tonight right
King H1 just feels wrong I mean yeah in
the corner why would you
and
I wonder yeah well maybe rookie 2 is a
playable moving fact rookie two just
trade and if black captures over there
A6 Pawn is hanging in the end I don't
think
I don't think it's all that dangerous
for why okay but there's probably a lot
of different ways we might get into some
end game work yeah there will be some
sort of Queen end game there will be the
the results are like Queen C3 and once
again I mean you have to calculate all
the stuff like Queen takes attacking the
Knight or or just Knight F5 for what I
mean so it's one of the hardest things
to do is just when you have a couple
choices you can have this end game that
end game maybe you get two or three
different choices you have to find just
the right one yeah so in reality what
happened was Knight to D5 all right so
he captures 935 so this is arguably a
bit more forcing in line because after
Rook B2 rookie two in order to say
capture on ah no no no no nothing works
because he absolutely has to take on E2
right we need to know yeah he has to
trade the night in order to win the pool
uh well not win the pawn back he is I
mean material is equal so he tries to
win the ball 95 85 and then black has a
choice I just realized black has a
choice of three points but I don't
really see any any
kind of any way of be sure that black
has the advantage right because A6 is
hanging in two cases and if Queen A4
then Queen E5 you do have the side fast
Pawn but the king is very vulnerable so
there will be interesting and this is
where they are now he's deciding which
Pawn to recapture yeah yeah and it kind
of has me wondering did I mean it felt
like black had something at some moment
like he had a good position I'm
wondering if he did or if it was always
just gonna inevitably lead to something
no no no I think yeah like I mean once
again if we because in this moment where
we left it it felt so good that is that
is much better for black and queen C6
overlooked Knight D5 so Queen C6
actually the move that I was praising
yeah Knight D5 was a very nice resource
and compy recommends just to go back to
F6 because this Knight F4 sacrifice in
this setup probably never happens so
just return the Knight back to F6 you
had me excited I thought you were gonna
say you just play NADA for this is what
I missed there was some Mega exciting
tactic but we were discussing yeah that
sometimes Knight F4 would be an idea so
since it doesn't work you just return
maybe you have G4 ideas maybe now Queen
C6 that you have D5 covered I had to
maybe identify this Knight D5 wasn't
easy to see all right so we are already
here okay on C3 white captured only six
Queen D2 check so this way he ends up up
a pawn I'm guessing
just keep going
so it's not impossible they will see
another drawing oh my gosh he has five
draws in a row looking to make it number
six potentially yeah right I don't think
you can say black has any advantage
anymore right no I think it's not at all
draw seems like almost inevitable when
it's gonna be this wide open
all right well we'll keep her we'll come
back and we'll see what actually does
end up happening here but uh what else
yeah chat mentioned something uh about a
boss serve oh all right let's take a lot
of stuff uh they say yeah they are
talking about kind of previous previous
things in the game missed E5 E4 which
would given him like a huge Advantage
I'm not sure which moment was it he yes
E5 let's play T5 G5 I don't think E4
here because the knights hangings right
apparently Knight H5 Queen G4 Rook F1
and probably here E4 it just it just
shuts down all of the white pieces yeah
and it lets you kind of keeps you
wondering why naughty for indeed because
you you can also think of F5 and say if
white does what he was doing then even
F5 uh Pawn takes and I imagine the point
would be that we take with the pawn
intending to play five once again
because of the queen G6 you know Bishop
is kind of vulnerable maybe say just
play this threaten Rook GA threatened my
G3 in some cases I can easily imagine
something like this working for black
yeah yeah okay so maybe there was a
missed opportunity there and where are
they all right where are they now we've
seen A5 preventing night before Bishop
went to F3 Rook G8 is yeah like
mysterious Rook move but once again he
wants to play a five and recapture with
the pawn when he's not attacking that
beep on he's gonna make sure it's
protected hore F5 Queen to H3 Rook h8
okay
so that's yeah not so bad it no longer
looks as bad as it was H1
still the pieces are somewhat
somewhat tying down yeah
um
how do we how do we kind of I know you
really want to solve the problem yeah
this night this night's not very not
very useful yeah not very useful on the
drive you can build Knight F4
yeah I almost want to when I say yo
Bishop F4 and Knight G3 and if it
happens it's cool and all but then the
bish1 F4 is
you know
maybe just take Queen F3 or take rookie
one still very easy to blunder something
that that's kind of the bottom line uh
when it is down to
four minutes only after this okay what
move are they on here that's move 32 so
still still eight more moves steel eight
more moves slightly difficult ten so we
will see what is happening in this one
could you bring our attention to the
cadrich game and see if there's any
developments yeah yeah so that's B
tournament and indeed I keep forgetting
that we have one more leader yeah
who is facing Dennis cartridge Dennis
coverage if you remember I mean ah no it
wasn't him but in B tournaments someone
was always in the time trouble remember
we had the guy who would who would be
like
15 minutes or so uh some country's game
looks like it's in progress steel I
don't quite understand what's going on
and surprise surprise
surprise surprise Dennis College himself
will be joining me in a studio analyzing
his game which he apparently won
I reckon yes that's how this 30 minutes
delay Works ladies and gentlemen
so we are speculating on what's going on
what's going to happen it's such an
exciting position it turns out the
player already finished the game
took trouble and we are very grateful
for this took trouble to join us in a
studio and yep
uh hopefully we are ready yeah welcome
welcome so now you know where the studio
is yes
to the chess house now you know you go
to the chess house and you'll tell us
everything what goes on in this
tournament because you started quite a
while then something went not according
to planner well I like the to be honest
all of the games I was kind of winning
like the only game I wasn't winning like
winning winning was against like Brandon
I was there maybe only plus one and a
half I would say uh plus one and a half
only only yes yes and I made like half
out of three out of those three games so
yeah pretty pretty bad for me but I
guess I guess the swing nullifies it a
little bit Yeah so you've taken over one
of the tournament leaders right yes and
where's the key in the Indian defense
yeah if I can tell correctly and uh very
very
funny line I want to say I mean
eight seven eight six it just said
recently I was I don't know giving some
kids Claws and we well it came about
this position in the Kings Indian we are
discussing the main line Knight C6 and
how it is nowadays in sort of a crisis
and then someone came up that you can
play literally anymore why was the move
from Queen E8 I don't know B6 even even
today I think I was looking at the
engine like one of the first choices is
actually like rookie eight now rookie so
basically yeah
anyway so can you can you tell us a
little bit like the okay the J general
idea of course it's a preparation you
don't have I mean yeah but I would say
there are like two main ideas like one
is if he goes Bishop P3 we now have
Knight G4 of course yeah so yeah Bishop
G5 anymore and the other one is like to
maybe sometimes go even Knight age seven
an ag5 that's also sometimes an idea
yeah so here here they mostly play uh uh
I guess like or d e or D5 but he played
the best move rookie one is by far the
best move and now Knight bd7 no it'd be
the same so what's interesting I just
discovered that for instance they was
played by Fabiano caruana already so
whenever computer shows something strong
like the strong play is the immediately
it is Battle tested yes they try it out
so maybe this and now here this is the
best thing like if you if he goes now
Bishop of one let's say because like
that's the most logical for me right now
here black can play like or Knight H7
that's an idea and now like then
sometimes yes and now like if you go
Bishop E3 let's say you jump anyways
Knight G5 Knight G5
uh HG yes and now like if you play let's
say F3 or something here actually a very
good position for Blackie to just take
1v4 immediately uh Bishop before and now
just B6 and stuff like this and like
engine and you love this position for
black uh of these guys are swapped then
you have a very nice yes you put a
knight 25 to go King G7 Rook hate Queen
F6 it's really like actually a very nice
position because you have an idea even
though the squares look very bad there's
a very nice idea later on when the net
goes on D5 that you play C5 he moves
like maybe we could yeah construct it
okay let's say like let's say things
does something a check let's say 95
whatever 95 Bishop B7 Rook B1 and now
here the idea will be let's say I play
Rook h8 first okay now you play
something B3 or something whatever yeah
I just want to like show it like it it
is like C5 idea when he moves the queen
back you actually just take on the
mistake Rook D5 and then Queen F6 so
that's only one weakness which is easy
to guard and now here I actually have
queen of four ideas also to protect you
over the H5 it's very very interesting
that's a very bad Bishop on F1 yeah
that's kind of of one idea is but you
don't have to plan edit so you can also
just play or rookie eight or cease
things getting a very normal but Queen
C2 is the best move rookie I actually
played against chefchenko the same line
and I didn't know Queen C2 so I played
some C6 but what is there definitely
better third kit is the best now he
should take d-e-d-e I knew all of this
because basically because he also plays
himself the H6 I have really yeah so
Bishop B3 C6 and now there's 94 was it
was played by Prague I remember correct
turns out yeah yeah it is uh yeah
yeah so 0.7 I think was also played in
this game even though I'm pretty sure
it's not the best move yeah you're
following the game yeah yeah here it is
and and I knew that like the idea of
Queen C7 is the now C5 is not so good
because of B5 all right so C6 Pawn is
protected so that was the whole idea of
27 States and queen C7 yes but I think
he played if I remember correctly
because I was looking a little bit like
what the engine light suggests that he
played the best move just like Rook 81.
now here to be honest I started to think
I didn't really know what what am I
doing like because if I go night of
Faith the problem with night of faith if
I just want to go this is like Bishop C5
I think Bishop C5 is very annoying and
he'll put the definition Queen yeah that
looks very
ugly
yeah so you're gonna have to keep the
Knight on D7 b66 B4 Bishop to f8 okay
and now I got this position I'm pretty
sure he's just better here but I have no
idea like okay I mean this is all I
think kind of force let's say hey I
didn't know what to do you have to you
have to go to B8 it seems no but here he
started like this G4 okay no this is
this all okay H3 I think was okay I
think I think it's three yeah probably
no no this move I don't like by him and
he went G4 yeah because that kind of
very aggressive right yeah very
aggressive he probably could try to do
something a bit more I was thinking like
maybe 92 93 just
yep so that's a suggestion for him to
improve
anyway let's yeah let's go with the flow
G4 Queen B2
Knight D7 so well like got the time to
develop the bishop yeah I mean here now
I also have sometimes ideas to go like
even over the a file like to maybe go
like a rook A6 through K8 and then a b
but okay I also have to be careful
because he can sacrifice always on B5 so
it's not so simple
but here in 92 no here something went
wrong for me yeah King H1 now here he he
didn't he he wasn't even looking what I
was doing to be honest to have a feeling
because here I'll order the low my
position okay so G5 and Knight goes
not here he went for H4 but I think
that's just not good
he's taking the pawn and just
so yeah that's perhaps the pawn that any
Kings Indian player is happy to
sacrifice right I mean I mean now
everything is where on the forest
everything just works everything
everything just is amazing now for me I
have feeling wow Knight H7 and you
capture it went Knight G5 so all the
dark squares right yeah
[Music]
I think it's over because he now has
like a trick if I don't play [ __ ]
before that he's gonna go like Knight D5
and then next move I hear yeah
95 and I always say this and then like
d695 before now he doesn't really think
have anything
so he well no wait that's right yeah
that's that's wrong we don't have the
end of the game we are lagging yeah okay
half a year sorry half a half an hour
behind 95 was the move Knight D5 yeah
was the move in the game yeah I mean he
didn't know what to do so he did that uh
Wikipedia thanks Bishop C8
he took now Bishop B5 because because he
plays D6 I'll just go Queen C6 so Bishop
B5 and now Rook B8
and now I copied only like two things D6
is one after which Queen B7 I go
and now after Bishop E2
I don't actually take on before but I
play Bishop D7 I think that's like just
yeah just lock those guys lock
everything and now and now I think
should be over Bishop C6 is coming and I
blocked everything and what did he do in
the game he played the queen B7 and he
played oh no he didn't play D6 right no
no yeah he played here Queen E2
yes Queen B7
Bishop D3
Queen before and here just a very nice
line just to show it like if it goes
Rook B1
take
take yeah Bishop takes 91 91 Bishop A6
ah Queen E4
and now Bishop D Bishop D3 is a pleasant
yes right very nice the queen is
overloaded yeah Queen E4 actually was
attacking this
was saying that's the thing
I mean it's still winning but I this is
a nice one that's a beautiful win so
yeah he didn't go for that he played
after Queen before and before he played
now uh Quincy too but that that already
yeah it was Rook H3
uh
uh wait what if you play here now he
played Bishop G6
fg6 okay here now he gets a little bit
tricky like Knight E4
before if I take Queen E4 Queen E4
so here uh I played Rook C3
Queen E2
Queen C4
Queen E1
and now I took no wait what did I don't
know I played okay took something
no I played now let's move Rook D3 Rook
D3 Rook D3 that's it three he played
Knight C6 Rook D1
25.
wow now of course we had to have to head
to see it till the very end that's a
that's a beautiful finish uh anyway
congrats seems like you're back on track
hopefully hopefully and yeah good luck
with the tournament end game so you
still have three three games to play and
yeah and I will be back just in a second
be hookers we will have another winner
of one of the games uh Brendan Jacobson
won his game is a game against
Chandra akshat and that's what we will
have
right now guys
just quickly while Brandon takes his
seed a quick update yeah so Yugi has one
nejnik saved his game for a draw against
one win
and Hans his game well kinda heads
towards a draw but I'm not 100 sure
anyway anyway please welcome Brendan
Jacobson with his win against Chandra
uh so hi how's it going it could be
better it could be worse
um definitely not happy with my chest
this tournament but I'll take the wins
as they come uh all right yeah well as
you know that's kind of outside Observer
it seems that you're perhaps one of the
few people who actually care about how
interesting the games are for sure
because yeah well there are very sort of
efficient guys right you know who are
trying to be and every time you play a
game it's it's entertaining so that
that's you get thank you very much from
the commentators at the very least right
yeah I know I figure even if I'm losing
I may as well put up a fight like
against both ronak and uh Candor like
um okay I played this interesting line
of the names of against Roanoke which
backfired but I figured at least it's
worth trying to fight because he's super
well prepared of course he was well
prepared against what I played too but I
figured that was worth a try and against
Cantor I played the modern just because
you know at this point I'm just trying
to have fun with the tournament it's
definitely not going my way so yeah I'm
just trying to play interesting chess
and see where it goes
um yeah going to this game I figured I
wanted to stabilize a bit I didn't
really prepare at all for this game
um I sort of just wanted to relax and
come back stronger after the tough loss
yesterday
um yeah so I threw this bishop T2 line
at him I haven't looked at the details
of this in quite a bit of time but I
figured it would be a surprise for for
him as well
um right and as far as I can tell like
people usually play it as some strange
Queen's gun between the bishopone D2 so
you're pretty much doing all the same
like Bishop D3 and try to play over the
C file right is that the idea right
Bishop D3 Bishop B7 and some Knight B5
move yeah so I mean the main line by far
is is castling here and that leads to
some pretty wild complications because
white will eventually play for 95 and F4
and at least like for example Bishop f8
after castle Yeah castle if we're into
console because I remember some high
rated kind of high profile games must be
there right definitely yeah it's a
bishop f8 we still have like Vivid games
our team Eve against the Mingus and so
on and so on right and then you'd go 95
eventually and Sport it was a four right
exactly yeah and it leads to some crazy
crazy lines with that foreign
that sort of thing
okay so yeah I couldn't remember the
exact details of that line
um so and I knew Knight B5 was somewhat
of a safe try I know that the only thing
I remembered about this line is that
Black's cleanest equality is the plane
that A6 here like day six uh interesting
and the point is okay I can't take on B4
and take on C7 because you're just a
rook C8 trick
it's nice yeah and look to see one and
you might even think oh okay I haven't
met when you ever captured The Rook
Knight D3 just wins everything right so
okay that's sort of a better version of
what happened or what he got
um because after take take I mean my
knowledge ended here but I just knew
that why it was supposed to have a very
slight Advantage
um because okay Black's Bishop's a bit a
bit bad and it's pretty solid for white
always
um pieces are pretty well placed yeah
after 94 I couldn't figure out the the
correct way of playing this I mean I
wasn't sure whether the queen should go
on C2 or D1
um
Queen D1 felt right to me but okay I see
now the computer is not agreeing with me
hey
um I don't think you should pay
attention to the to this particular
machine sure it's not very kind of not
very deep sure sure okay it does say
queen C2 is like that marginally better
but
once again yeah okay yeah so after C5
yeah here I just totally lost my mind
um I mean okay I was calculating a lot
of different stuff for example let's say
I start with D takes C5
uh if you take C5 Bishop takes E4 here
you can go Rook takes E4
and the problem is that I can take on C5
videos Queen B6 and even consider going
rotates D5 here
it takes Queen takes and then Queen C6
and okay I mean probably white shouldn't
be worse here with two pawns and but
yeah I figured it probably wasn't enough
for but like really nothing it would
seem that yeah something should work but
nothing really does yeah exactly
um and instead of
d365 I can also play something sort of
slow with like B3 just to stop C4 yeah
and then just castle and sort of play
this position maybe it's a bit
comfortable for white just playing for a
slight Advantage but yeah in the game I
mean I castled thinking okay you can go
C4 and I would take on e4 and then
Knight D2 and then I quake with like A4
and B3 so that isn't good and then so
instead he should go like A6 or 1997 or
something like that and then I'll
probably go B3 and get something similar
and I just completely forgot he could
take on C3 and go C4 like I I a six
Knight C3 uh so this one is completely
blundered yeah
um and yeah I'm already in serious
danger being worse here honestly um
because okay it's getting C4 B5 super
quickly and I'm not my pieces aren't
really well placed here actually if I
want to play for E4 it's only a few more
moves to set it up
um
so yeah so we captured with the pawn
right C4 here I spent a lot of time
because I needed to make a decision do I
want to play ambitiously here and risk
more or I can sort of just wait
passively it's for example like
objectively I would assume I should go
Bishop C2
and then just try to put like a forward
B1 and try to hold inside together I
mean clearly White's not playing for
anything and I'm just trying to to
equalize here but I I figured Bishop B1
is a lot more interesting just playing
for a quick like Knight D2 rookie one
like before E4 even so I mean of course
like this should be nothing for white
but I think he already started to go
around here so he he spends a bit of
time he played Knight Knight C6 yeah
Knight D7 we can see it recommended by
the engine right 96 felt like a step in
the wrong direction I think 97 was was
former logical
um
B5 Rook 31.
and he's very serious about this queen
side right right yeah I think he was
counting on his counter play with B4
against my E4 plan but I think he was
just a bit too slow so that's exactly
what happened yeah E4 B4 because we got
distracted from this game somewhere
around this point e to D5 Queen D5 and
sorry I don't want to steal the show for
too long
of course so after he takes D5
um if he takes on E1 here yeah yeah sure
you can do this queen takes D1 Queen
takes D5 and now Bishop E4 Queen B5 is
sort of a better version for black
because my queen is misplaced but I
think I have a queen E4 instead of
Bishop E4 which is quite strong
um
because he has some trouble with his
pieces in the same game and like ah
right so if he takes you just take with
the bishop and somehow he's he's
probably down right like there are some
tricks with like Knight takes D4 and 92
at some point like let's say he could
start with Rook E8 for example
um I thought maybe like F3
but now you can go B take C3 and then
Knight takes D4 it takes C3 Knight takes
D4 with the Knight E2 trick and I
couldn't make sense of all these lines
but yeah I figured at minimum I can go
over to take C4 and even these end games
where it's all simplified is still a bit
tricky for black with the a punk with
the back crank and the a pawn being yeah
yeah right so in the game though after
Queen Dixie 5 immediately which I think
was correct
um Bishop E4 Queen B5 uh so Queen to D5
Bishop E4 would be fine in my first
instinct like chroma FEMA is back was to
go A4 to throw an A4 here which looks
right but the promise you can take Rook
B1 he has Knight B4 here which wow I
think
seems like really dangerous for me yeah
we don't know if it actually works but
right during the game it's easy to get
scared of it exactly and once I saw that
I was like okay I don't want any part of
this so
so yeah I think I made the correct
decision to take it yeah so you captured
them and it feels to me like somehow
black should be able to sack upon in a
way where you get some activity and
probably has decent drawing chances like
maybe the best try for black is take on
D4 instead of B4
um so like Knight to D4 right so let's
say a bishop takes B7 Queen takes B7 or
it takes C4
and then like Rook ed8 for example
and I think maybe this was a better try
because at least black has some activity
for the pawn here I mean okay white
should still be pushing at least but
but yeah I think this was a better drive
for him
so he'll definitely win he's going back
right yeah like ba5 though in
not sure if he can take on A5 but that's
true
who knows yeah
okay yeah maybe not first answer this
but but I feel like somehow there should
have been a better track because in the
game I mean it felt like sort of a clean
pun out for me although it wasn't it
still wasn't that easy for me to convert
but he was super low on time also and it
felt like my moves were pretty natural
ah right so it's just somewhere around
this point I just didn't pay attention
to the clock it was already down to like
two minutes only yeah in the defender's
position with a minute on your clock is
a nightmare
traded over here Knight C4 and it is it
is an extra opponent and then
were there like
other yeah I think he started to go
wrong around here maybe you should play
something like Rook da and just try to
immediately get counter play like sack
A5 and then go like Queen
I don't know
um A7 or
somehow just try to win one of the pawn
backs one of the pawns back and then
hopefully hold on there
um because the way he played in the game
after Knight E3 and once I got in like
D5 and Rook C4 and I make space for my
king it feels pretty smooth for white
yeah D5 he can never take because
this well if Rook 65 actually 93 might
be yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah I should
go Rook C4 and Rook D4 Rook C4 B4 is
yeah Rook C5 that's
funny right check yeah everything's in
trouble here yeah
this is a threat this is a threat
capturing the Knight it's Queen E3 whoa
yeah I have to be tricky till they have
a rather pay attention to the tricks
till the very end right no I was
stressed here like considering the
things I've been missing this tournament
like even here I was making sure to stay
accurate and spend the time um
to put them away right but he played the
five and yeah he got down to the last
few seconds and he just panicked here
and then
before uh yeah and you're winning on the
phone yeah but anyway overall like under
the circumstances you said like like you
were doubting yourself every other move
right so that seems to be like a great
game great comeback right yeah yeah what
can I say
good luck with the remaining with the
end game as I say today end game of the
tournament three last rounds and uh you
know a lot of games were saved or even
one of the end games maybe yeah maybe
it'll have a better luck great yeah
thank you thanks very much for joining
and we will be back with Jonathan very
very soon
all right and meanwhile I'll check
never-ending game between the foreign
and hunts
past the time control it's already
something
and it's not a draw
which is awesome yeah enhances Pawn
wants to make three moves in a row and
promote and win the game
can this be right
yep just let me see yeah of course
corners of course if you ask the engine
it's always a draw engine is good at
finding those like perpetuals or or
fortresses or whatever it is but I'd be
scared
being a party not be scared that this
Pawn is actually running quite fast
that's right and I'm glad to be back
with you Miro I'm back in yeah uh yeah
it's
screen right because it looks like I
mean these kind of queen Pawn things
where things are wide open it always
feels like maybe this is Perpetual but I
mean obviously there's that e-bond
running down so how do you do it uh
there must be a way but can we figure
out kind of tricky right so it might be
that once again computer gives you well
that's equal sure it probably is yeah
but yeah but you check and it's one you
know one straight line
correctly
this right he captures and then you go
E5 and you say okay this is I actually
have no idea I didn't share but like
yeah but imagine this being yeah
and all the rest would be white be be
lost yeah so that's still some pressure
on a paren even though objectively
perhaps it's a draw all right
[Music]
against a passive they've also passed
the time control above is an exchange
down but he has some threads I believe
he has some threats to this King so we
could we could actually check what
happened
it's a queen H3 I believe we've seen
near Rook HH Rook H1 Rook E3 and Rook d8
guards the pawn how did he ended up
losing an exchange or sacrificing in
exchange should I say G6 rookie 2 95.
okay that that's the one Queen A6 C4 and
he decided to Simply or maybe there was
no way back maybe there was no way back
I think a lot of these night
interference tactics yeah but it doesn't
look all that depressing for black
because now he's threatening with C2 of
the king A1 Bishop E5 once again as rat
Rook B1 and E Queen even like Queen C2
or a by the way A4
what does white do after A4 it's a big
big question because A3 is a serious
sweater here A3 is a serious threat uh
trying to guard on the third rank at
least with the Rook maybe Queen F3 works
but Rook H3 I'm sure does not
Rook takes B2
or
doesn't it work I mean I was pretty
confident it doesn't work because of
some discovered maybe this works in fact
look C2 check
[Music]
everything's hanging so there might be
some trouble yeah fitted our tournament
leader potentially in a lot of trouble
here and uh I also want to take just a
little bit of time you know I'm just I'm
kind of gathering my thoughts I'm
getting back into this thing and we
actually have a question for you from
the trap and this is from YouTube chat
this is Patrick Daly he is asking he's
got a question from Miro about niece
Nick's game yesterday since he missed
the beginning of the broadcast Miro are
you surprised that Ilya dropped that
position or not now if you remember
yesterday was kind of struggling to
defend that position against you Yang Yi
uh are you actually surprised by the
result that you Yang Yi was able to
convert it I believe this is the
question
um right it's kind of twofold because uh
once again the game was yesterday and we
also started to look at from not from
the very beginning so the initial
position that say happened after the
opening the end game where white is
perhaps marginally better it is somewhat
surprising right yeah but I think when
we've tuned in already Ilya had this
silly night on A6 yes it was there for
quite a while and yeah and usually with
it's very easy to misplay this kind of
position so that's what I'm probably
gonna say so computer might say yeah it
is defendable you just have to be
precise but that's exactly what's hard
right I mean when your pieces are we
humans are not that bad at chess when
the moves are logical right I mean so
you give me the open file I'll be able
to swap all the roads you give me this
episode this I can do perfectly right
give me an outpost for the night I'll
get the night to The Outpost but yeah
but if it's like a really weird looking
setup and you have to come up with
precise moves all the way it's very easy
to misplay and once again White had the
initiative so it was easier for white to
play very nice right sir thank you and
yes if you guys do have your questions
please make sure you send them in in the
chat or in the comments if you're
watching this after we've been uh this
has been published on YouTube all right
and what that let's get right back in to
the action yeah I just realized that
Union Plus two and he probably joins the
leaders unless yeah
one of them at least one of them wins
operating doesn't look like he he can
win so we're still waiting to see what
happens in the Opera and vidit is also
in a bit of a trouble so yeah he might
be yeah wow
and these guys for quite a while they
are playing a very very well what
originally looked like like a dead draw
in game so let me quickly run through
this game so it was a Catalan right
white has played G3 in Catalan with
Knight C3 move yeah today earlier in the
club I was talking about this line what
do you say you're not supposed to do it
it's an interesting thing like like it's
uh quite
you know quite a tricky option instead
of like a usual Castle which is much
more theoretized like everything
everyone knows literally everything D
takes Knight D5 just a quick shout out
to Queen D6 move which was played by
Amon the others he car on the camera
okay 26. so yeah it's it's sharp but it
seems it works because Knight C6
that usually pretty much what white
wants
so the whole trick here
is that
there is such position with the Knight
on B1 and short cars right okay well
uh Black's responses are a C5 or D5 and
at safe Black Goes exactly as as in this
line so Bishop E3 the whole point is
that white is planning to Castle long oh
interestingly enough so opposite castles
you would say the open B file and so on
but it turns out that the bishop is
almost useless Bishop B7 white always
the plays F3 which was not very active
B2 is easy to guard with the King on C1
with zukon D2 if needed and white enjoys
this little positional Edge and there
were games there were games with long
Castle I believe uh Hikaru by the way
lost himself against Fabi Karana here at
zinfeld cup
some five years ago so that's a tricky
line after night D5 yes indeed White
Castle's short
rookie one Queen B4 and very often
something like this would happen so this
end game with opposite colored Bishops
white sometimes be Pawn up sometimes
would just have somewhat better
structure the thing is black is always
kind of struggles a little bit I don't
want to say like black is always worse
but struggles a little bit
so C3 yeah that's a nice way of not
dropping the C4 Pawn but rather getting
something like that where you would
think okay but there is absolutely
nothing for white
the position should be dead equal but it
tends to be why it still has some ideas
so C4 bones hanging he blocks the B file
F4 I honestly I don't like very much I'd
prefer F3 to restrict the bishop but
anyways and perhaps uh theodoro decided
that he needs more space on the on the
king's side
and that's what happens and still I mean
it it's uh like not not a huge Pawn but
it's still a pawn bishop A5 and you
cannot play C6 because Rook D6 this
somewhat annoying rook d8 and Rook
enters
but still but black has to be precise
like still has to be precise and now C6
Bishop C6 Rook F5 and now it's already
an extra pawn and not doubled because
white tomato white can take only five
yeah very nice so black is getting
slowly out played in this same game
that's what I want to say yeah nice nice
from Nicholas it looks like maybe Rooks
will be coming off we might have
obviously colored Bishops do you think
there's a real serious chance of winning
this game no but that that's what he's
thinking right now because he can trade
the Rooks and B2 pawns up it seems
because there is no way of guarding C7
so he will calculate try to calculate
everything he wants to if it works or
not yeah if it doesn't win he always has
a plan B he can take only five with the
rook and that's you cannot tell if it's
winning or not but that's always better
right I mean it's an extra Pawn with the
Rooks with more active pieces so two
very attractive options he just has to
decide which one he will he will prefer
all right so we'll see what Nicholas
theodoro comes up with here this is one
to keep some attention on yeah yeah
and yeah once again just a quick update
of partying against Neiman uh yeah the
E4 King to F1 was played by Gregory
apparents Queen E2 as a reply to E3 said
or maybe not even playing we need to no
you have to I just realized I wanted to
say queen guards E2 so no threats and
you can push your ball but there is one
little threat Queen F2 Checkmate in one
pretty good big threat yeah yeah so
you'll have to play Queenie too
and maybe that's how the game ends I
mean captures black picks this one with
a check but then white has checks then
black has checks and it's okay so this
could very easily be fizzling out then
into a draw yeah but for now it's Hans
who is trying I mean who's trying to win
interesting so we'll see if he comes up
with something more interesting here
right and in the other one yeah did it
since he's got uh no abusive since he's
got half an hour so when it was thinking
yeah when it was thinking but let's move
like for video it was in a way easier
because that's off the move 40 Queen C2
is a big threat you have to go King A1
after Bishop E5 uh I bet you have like
strictly only move to protect B2 which
is Rook B1 and then a boss up of course
is looking for a way to continue he's
got quite a few of those
well other than you know just keep
pushing the uh yeah what's the other
option yeah I don't know you could just
play something gotta centralize they say
yeah we need four and start pushing the
Deep one maybe you don't need Queen E4
at all maybe you go D4 immediately even
before D3 I mean how bad can it be with
the pawn on D3 with the Rook on the
second rank yeah it's a serious Pawn
Yeah I actually think black might be
just better yeah because it's the first
illusion the first impression like you
still have the image of white
controlling the game being better
attacking you know the weaknesses and
then you think okay and now white is
exchange up so he converted his
Advantage into something material
converted and it turns out that yeah he
perhaps just got outplayed and it's
black who is Black who is running the
show now
um okay so just quickly let's check the
B tournament we've got couple of results
here yeah cut which has one with black
Jacobson one with white
we still have uh cheryla and you again
with a Christian how is Christian doing
Christian
as per usual he just made the time
control requirement their game just
reached move 40. uh Christian it looks
like I mean first of all it looks like
his position is very good he's probably
winning and I'm trying to see if the
sexual look here the second observation
both Kings been through some storm you
know
how did this happen
ing
exactly
G3 in rui Lopez all right what happened
six Knight F6 so far so good d3b5
no big surprises here C3 oh rather yeah
after D3 I just didn't mention so D3 and
move five black actually very often goes
for Bishop C5 instead of Bishop E7 right
so
he must have had a very good reason to
play D3 here and one of the guesses
would be that he appointed his opponent
was intending to play this so-called
open Spanish right it's a castles and
then black girls 94. right that's called
open always happy to see this avoided
yeah but no I mean just making a point
that other moves and thank you foreign
theoretical so to speak and then white
can play D3 having the same positions in
the game in reality right but uh the
primary black from the option of playing
Bishop C5
so that's unless you're afraid of the
open Spanish unless your porn plays the
open Spanish then 5d3 sort of less
precise than 63. but anyway those are
those are like subtleties nobody cares
about D6 C3 castles rookie one
Knight A5 C5 so basically we are talking
like what's it called the chigorean I
think the chigorean variation of Marie
Lopez with white being a full Tempo down
perhaps right because he played D3 and
D4 yeah and normally the pawn goes to D4
in one go but the thing is black has
spent this Tempo in H7 H6 which arguably
can be a harmful move later on because
the pawn can be targeted like especially
if the center gets blocked okay it
didn't get blocked in our game but very
often in you know in the chiguring white
would go D5 and all those karpovian
games D5 G4 Knight to G3 blah blah and
then the power lead 6 might actually be
a Target so it's always something black
it is to worry about yeah so that's why
like a full trade on D4 those are
very often black doesn't really care
about this little weakness on D6 and has
has very decent counter play on
semi-open files and looking for D5 and
he deep play D5 okay so how come
Christian managed to
you don't see how the king gets to G3
yeah not yet so Bishop B4 Knight E4 of
course we are sacrificing in exchange
and I guess after Bishop E1 some Knight
D6 why it is just much better so
therefore
the night was not taken rookie 2 Rook to
C4 Bishop B3
black could have traded Queens but then
I just realized yeah
because you know me I'm a pensioner I
really like trading the Queens whenever
I get the chance but then
uh you'd like the Wardrobe D7
but doing so it's even worse because E6
right so so you really can't allow
yourself to trade on D1 so Rook D4 Queen
C2
between this and still doesn't look any
bad for black if you ask me I don't know
something yeah I mean this has to be an
acceptable position for black
Bishop D5 traded a check B3 so perhaps
oh well black went on the very very
aggressive way G5 for whatever reason
and then a check all right
yep E6 Queen A1 oh threatening a check
made his thought but Bishop ba all the
way Bravo Christian
you can see one capture and now the
closed King is weaker now uh yeah he
doesn't want to capture because I I
guess just check rookie 4 and F3 if
needed yeah the kingdom G3 is perfectly
safe it turns out
rookie 3 Queen
yeah it is it actually is but I had this
like major attack but the king just ran
away and now it looks like like first of
all first of all white could just trade
take on e4 he loses F7 but he is still
like a pawn up in the end game with
everything under control but Christian
of course you want to keep the queen
yeah he played Queen E8 which is a very
good move of course Bishop D5 and just
goes back to HD yeah just run away goes
back to H2 there is uh well there are
some difficulties guarding the f8 bishop
yeah it looks like Christian's winning
here he started off a little bit a
little bit you know it was a bit of a
rocky start but you know he's been he
won yesterday he's coming back and he's
kind of getting himself back into this
tournament which is great to see him yep
all right and with that let's actually
go ahead and take a look at our
standings
all right while we're having the issues
again uh maybe maybe you guys can hear
us maybe you can't but maybe we could
just real quick uh have a look at the
standings for the a group here they are
obviously we still have some games going
on but we have you Yang Yi sitting at
the top of the leaderboard for now with
four and a half Four Points we still
need to see what's happening in the
Vivid game but perhaps he is in a little
bit of trouble o'parent is going up
against Hans Neiman probably a draw but
we're not quite sure yeah so that's the
feeling so yum Yi he will not be the
sole lead but it's unlikely that he will
not be tied correct right because
neither did it no apparents seem to win
their game so well perhaps not both not
going to lose so someone will be tied
with me
so that is what we are waiting to see on
that game there's also a fun to win an
ilionic both kind of hanging in there
with three and a half and three points
respectively obviously then we still
have quite a lot of game it's not even
worth talking about we'll have some
updated standings for you tomorrow when
we have a little bit more information
Mira what's going on in the beach in the
big group let's see so Ronald sadhwani
has lost and without due respect he
mathematically cannot remain in lead
because Christopher you and not
acceptable they are playing each other
so at least one of those will score
something yes so we'll see whatever
right well yeah we'll have somebody else
in the lead for uh absolutely
Dennis cartridge improves his situation
A girl likanto is still in the game so
might if he wins I didn't check his game
last but if he wins he might actually
join around like so one is somewhere and
stop in the tournament group everything
is so close everything is kind of coming
down to the wire and we only have three
more days of action here which is
actually kind of incredible so we are
looking forward to covering more of the
action tomorrow at 4pm Central Time
thank you so much to everybody hanging
out with us make sure if you are
following us uh that you watch the games
on us chess champs.com use the hashtag
fall chess classic and we will see you
guys tomorrow yeah we'll see you
tomorrow hopefully I think is going to
be the top and till tomorrow thank you
very much
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited